welcome to this video playing bill more
a boomerang does he play chess I don't
know okay let's see playing this funny
line again the good pride chick
variation yeah two together i think is
six i only have a very rough idea what's
going on here it's a somewhat honey
hybrids between the classical the soil
enter the night off at times let's see I
think you go a six here is it a six or
age 6 now maybe I can start with that
maybe knight c6 here yeah the ideas if
he goes Queen d2 a half 90 form this
typical maneuver compared to the to the
classical the zillion white he has
played f4 which is not happening there
all the time and of course he can play I
can play 94 now
a very typical tactical idea check all
the way back I guess maybe night be five
okay if you just place plays a quick
move g5 maybe yeah probably the only
thing that's so can happen is I'm of
course not super great in terms of
development here so this kind of quick
attacks could still could still strike
but before maybe going for the pin and
yeah should be good yeah this is a
rather annoying pin and I'm just one
away from castling another pawn that
I've one is a big central pawn not
something on the edge of the board
okay yeah it's a tricky for watching
yeah something like that now I'm trying
to do something on the C file
threatening to take on d4 and on c3 now
I don't need to castle right away let's
just keep this if it goes be four cannot
sacrifice on before we are probably I
can but it's it's it's over now this
idea on can I take it is it may doesn't
make any sense to check on c3 not really
am the dark squares on I just uh just
nice to nice to control yeah
that'sthat's okay and maybe I'm i have 9
a-5 next now still have not cancelled
but ok this looks good threatens to take
on b3 and play d4 and also night see
form can be can be possible okay 94 on
night takes b3 and this also looks looks
good okay
yeah how to see him continue here maybe
can I go h 5 h 5 f-5 Teague's it's got
he's got some compensation it's not
enough probably but it's still something
to to try Newcastle's looks looks risky
you read the special to f6 92 / should
have six yeah here I thought g5 but
maybe I'm I'm committing committing
suicide here okay just g 6 cm seems
better yeah the bishop may be on on g7
next should be be a good defense of
peace I wonder if I can get some some
counter play yeah g5 or or capturing
yeah maybe take it what about be five
then GF e five keeping the center just
as I didn't didn't really appreciate but
I can go to g7 right it's not
immediately immediately fatal I don't
see why I shouldn't take at the moment
I'm also in the pin now g5 to d2 okay um
we should be 52 to drive it back on
maybe I really don't see a big attack
coming here today only the only thing to
avoid is really getting checkmated
getting checkmated directly other than
that I'm just winning this with three
pounds and and then add the bishop pair
92 I got 22 now which really should be
good yeah mate on b2 cannot move the
night because the Queen hangs
white resigns yeah he stumbled right
into this 94 trick let's um let's see is
there some some way for white to get
again compensation I thought maybe night
be five yeah but he played played long
castles immediately maybe this to to to
try to to get the the night in the
outcome check to at least spoil my
castling but it's nothing nothing great
really am if we look at this can also do
this now maybe not but but a six or
something it looks it looks like just
the part I can also go rook somewhere
and King to have aid yeah okay well this
was played and you know maybe here
Bishop before wasn't really so so great
there should be seven f6 is also certain
destroying yeah but every are thinking
it was ok unless I'm overlooking
something here on my night b5 was
interesting then I have to return to c5
ok but the computer does not find
anything anything grateful wide so it
seems that I i was was ok all the way he
it's it's very tricky now with three
pawns the bishops there's no attack okay
thanks for watching